good boy here you go today we're
checking out the whissel health limited
this is a pet health tracker that will
not only track your dog's steps but it
also uses AI to basically give your dog
a voice you'll be able to track things
like licking how much sleep they've had
how much water they've drank and even
when they eat so inside of the app
you're able to see all sorts of things
so you can see when he was resting when
he went for his walk you can see if it
was a low intensity activity so he
walked for 1.3 miles the other thing
that I like is this will detect
different types of Trends something that
I noticed for Maddie wearing his whistle
is that he had a licking problem and
this was a few months ago and this
brought it to our attention because we
had never realized how much he actually
was licking and scratching I also really
like this this gives you the ability to
share Maddie's day so I can send this to
my friends and family this could also be
really great if you have dog walkers you
can add them on so they can share with
you all of the information about how
your pet was doing that day if you guys
want more information check out the link
to learn about how whissel health
limited helps pet parents take the best
possible care